قالت منظمه انسانيه عراقيه واجنبيه عامله
في اقليم كردستان شماليه العراق ان نحو
مليون عراقي اكثر من نصفهم من الاطفال
يفتقدون وثائق الهويه الاساسيه
واكدت هذه المنظمات ان هذا الامر يحرمهم
من حقوقهم الاساسيه كصحه والتعليم كما
يعرضهم للمساعده
مؤلم ومستقبل معتم هكذا تختصر النازحه ام
زينه حياتها مع اطفالها في هذا المخيم حيث
يدفعون ثمن ذنب لم يقترفوه كما تقول عايز
ست سنوات 2016
ام عبد هي الاخرى تحاول تعويض طفليها عن
المدرسه التي حرم من الالتحاق بها لعدم
امتلاكهما وثائق ثبوتيه بعد ان يئست من
مراجعه المنظمات
الاحداث طلعنا بقت المستمسكات بالبيت
وقصف البيت راحه المستمسكات رحت على قنديل
يقول ما نقدر نسوي كل شيء على مود الحكومه
العراقيه تعرفين الظروف صعبه
نحو مليون مواطن عراقي يفتقرون الى
الوثائق التعريفيه الاساسيه حسب ما كشفته
سبع مجموعات اغاثيه وبالتالي هم لا
يستطيعون الحصول على الخدمات الرئيسيه
كالصحه والتعليم ناهيك عن التهديدات
الامنيه في ظل غياب هذا العدد عن السجلات
الرسميه
لا تفهم او لا تستطيع استيعاب همم
احتياجات هذه الازمات الانسانيه في العراق
قوانين والتشريعات اكثر انسجاما مع
الاوضاع الانساني خصوصا اي انسان بدون
اوراق ويعتبر لان مجهول ما تعرفين شنو
رفضت مديريه الجنسيه في بغداد ونينوا
اطلاعنا على الاسباب التي تحول دون منح
السلطات العراقيه الوسائقه لهاؤلاء
النازحين
معوقاته انا عديده تحول دون حصول مئات
الاف العراقيين على وثائق ثبوتيه تنتشلهم
من حافه النسيان والتهميش ما لم تسارع
السلطات الى تذليلها فان حاضره ومستقبل
جيل باكمله مهددان بالضياع
حكيم الجزيره من مخيم حسن شام شرق الموصل